one of the things that I used to tell my
girls when they were getting a little
bit older and boys were taking an
interest was look we got some strict
rules with respect to dating and you
know that but I want you to understand
that the reason why we have these rules
is not because we're trying to deprive
you of something it's because we want
you to have the sort of relationship
that your mother and I have we want you
to be in a relationship that is safe and
that is secure but that is also exciting
and passionate and if a boy likes you
then for me what that says is that at
the very least he's got reasonably good
judgment because he he likes you but the
reason why we tell you that it's
appropriate to wait was because we want
someone worthy of you and when you meet
the person worthy of you you want to be
worthy of them that means thinking about
this not looking so much at what you
can't have right now but looking forward
to what you will have one day if you do
this right